a few days ago i was watching a video on
the nature of youtube's recommendation
system
i'm talking about youtube's ai that
recommends videos to you
i'll play a clip of this video right now
a couple of months ago i made a twitter
thread about some weird activity i saw
online and after i posted that thread
tons of engineers from many different
tech companies reached out to me
privately to tell me their stories
my interest in all this started one day
when i was scrolling on youtube and the
algorithm served up a pretty weird video
for me to watch
you know how the algorithm works right
it looks at your past activity and tries
to figure out what you could watch in
the future
that would keep you on the platform the
longest it optimizes watch time
the video is an excerpt from the channel
smarter every day
and in this video he goes on to explain
how people are
tailoring their videos to appeal to the
algorithm
so even if a video is of low quality it
is still somehow picked up
by the algorithm and recommend it to a
bunch of viewers
he explains this as an attack on the
youtube algorithm
and i highly recommend you watch his
video for the full scoop
but for this video i thought i would
look at recommender systems from a more
technical perspective
from that of a deep learning engineer
i'm not sure how
much you know this as viewers but in the
creator community
there's much talk going on about how
youtube tends to recommend videos
with higher watch time and watch time is
essentially just the length or
duration for which a video is watched
the idea is that longer the video is
watched youtube will push that up
in the rankings and so more people will
be able to see it
that's great but is the algorithm really
that simple
does it only value watch time when
recommending us videos
and in this video we're going to
actually take a look at just that
techie or non-techie you're going to
understand this video through and
through
even if you don't have any knowledge of
recommender systems so
if you want to learn more stay tuned
so we're going to talk about youtube's
recommendation system
and more specifically deep learning and
how neural networks fit in
let's take a concrete yet simple example
and see exactly how this is working
under the hood
say you're susan you own this platform
called youtube
where users can watch videos let's also
assume we only
have five videos on the platform videos
one through five
every online platform has users and
let's say that we have five of them too
users a through e
and now we have this little matrix
structure where
each cell represents whether a user
likes a particular video
or not note a matrix is a 2d assortment
of numbers
and in this context each cell can take
three types of values
it takes one if the user liked the video
a negative one if the user disliked the
video
and a zero if the user hasn't watched
the video and so hasn't rated the video
now these five users have watched and
rated whatever the videos they've seen
we show the results here in this matrix
we're making things simple
by stating that if a person has watched
a video they must either like or dislike
a video
they can't leave the video unrated a
property of this matrix
is sparsity every person has not watched
every video on youtube
even in this mini matrix example so
there is bound to be
some empty values and a lot of them
which i've labeled as zero here
now that we have our data let's make
some predictions
let us predict if a user d will like or
dislike video three
now how do we do this traditionally it's
done through a technique called
collaborative filtering the intuition
behind collaborative filtering
is collaboration we use the ratings of
older users to make predictions for
newer users
the same can be done for items we can
use the ratings on older items to make
predictions for
newer items when i say items in this
case
items are the same as videos on the
platform
i'll use them interchangeably depending
on whether we views
items or users we have a user user
collaborative filtering
and item item collaborative filtering
i'll talk about both
with a simple example now in user user
collaborative filtering
it's a two-step process first determine
how similar other users are
with this user d and then we use these
users to predict whether d
will like or dislike the video three
the intuition here is that similar users
will have similar interests
so if there are users who have the same
tastes as user d
and like video 3 then the chances are
that
user d will also like video 3. we're
making this prediction with numbers
that's the only difference
for the first step every user can be
represented by
the row of values this row of values is
called
a vector and we use the cosine
similarity formula to compute the
similarity between
two vectors this is just how
similarities are computed mathematically
and it's only one single way there are
other ways to also compute similarity
the similarity score can take values in
the range of well
cos theta which ranges between negative
1
and positive 1. now
why does cosine similarity work well
it's a direct measure of how close two
vectors are to each other
if user a and user b are similar to each
other
then the angle between them will be
small so
if theta is zero the users will have
identical tastes
and as the angle increases it means the
two users tastes
are more spread apart completely
opposite vectors
means that user a and user b have
opposite tastes
so if user a likes video 3 chances are
that user b
won't like it but while computing
similarity between users we cannot just
take
the direct cosign similarity between the
videos they like or dislike
some users may be more critical than
others so they tend to give more
negative reviews now to account
for this difference in grading we have
to normalize or
centralize the ratings this is done by
computing the mean
for every single user and then
subtracting it from
their corresponding ratings and this
will now bring the average rating for
every single user
to zero from this example you can see
that
user b and user e tend to be more linear
and give more
positive ratings so when user e says
that he dislikes video 3
this dislike is rated more heavily than
their liking
for the other videos in a similar way
users c
and d tend to be kind of strict in their
ratings so when user c says
they really like video two they really
like video too
and this like is rated more heavily than
their dislike for the other videos
i hope that makes sense now our goal is
to determine
if user d will like video 3.
this way we can determine whether we
should recommend the video to him or
just not we normalize the user vectors
already
now the next step is computing the
similarities between these vectors
and user d and this is done with the
cosine similarity
that i mentioned before remember
computing similarities is just to
determine which
users are more in line with user d so
that we can make recommendations based
on those users
looks like users a and d tend to have
opposite tastes
and this is because user a really
disliked video too while user d seemed
to really enjoy it
as for user b we can see that he agrees
with
d when it comes to the videos four and
five
users c and d agree with their dislike
of video 4.
and then we have user e whose similarity
with user d
can't really be attributed to a single
video review
at least in my opinion but i just
calculated it like i did for the others
and we actually see some agreement
between
users d and e next we make a prediction
consider the users who rated video three
in this case it's user c
and e now we take the weighted average
as the predicted rating we get a value
below zero
remember the average user rating for all
users is now zero
so chances are that user d may not like
video three
so we don't necessarily need to
recommend the video to them since
then chances are they don't like it
what about video one though well we do
the same thing
we make the prediction based on all
other users which is four of them here
and we take the weighted average rating
as the prediction
once again we get the value which is
less than zero so we don't recommend
this video to user d
either remember this type of
collaborative filtering is called
user user collaborative filtering it's
called so because we are comparing
different user interests in video 3 to
predict a new user's interest
in video 3. it's really easy to
implement right
but there's a problem with this say that
user d was
a business magnate and he spread the
word of this
online platform called youtube that's
just amazing
overnight the number of users increased
from five to five hundred
and the next night to five thousand and
then by the end of the month
i'm dealing with a million new users
this is amazing but the big question now
is
how does my algorithm deal with this
sudden burst
well let's see when an algorithm wants
to see if a user likes a particular
video
we have two steps to follow the first is
determine how similar
users are with this particular user
and then the second step is we use these
users to predict whether the current
user
will like or dislike the video the time
to do the first step is heavily
dependent on the number of users
because of this an explosion in users
will lead to a significant delay in the
algorithm
so user-based collaborative filtering
its pros are that well it's simple to
implement
whereas its major con is it doesn't
scale well
however there is another type of
collaborative filtering technique
called item-based collaborative
filtering it's quite easy to understand
the mechanics
because it's very similar to user-based
collaborative filtering
for the sake of comparison we'll try to
answer the same question as before
let's predict if the user d will like or
dislike
the video 3. the first step is the same
as we did with user-based collaborative
filtering
find the centered cosine similarities
but this time
it's between items and not between the
users themselves
so in this case it's between video three
and the other videos
next we compute the weighted average
rating this
is done by considering all items rated
by user d
and like before we get a value that's
less than zero
so we don't recommend video 3 to user d
notice that we do get actually similar
results to the previous approach of
user-based collaborative filtering and
this should usually be the case
now why does item-based collaborative
filtering usually perform better than
user-based collaborative filtering
well here's a few reasons items are much
easier to categorize than users
a user may be into science and
technology
entertainment videos educational videos
or even comedy videos
while a video itself doesn't belong to
all of these genres
so comparing them makes more sense than
comparing something as complex as
people users and another reason why
item-based collaborative filtering may
be better is simply because that
the number of videos or items on the
platform
doesn't really increase as fast as the
number of new users
on the platform so computing item based
similarities is less computation heavy
but even item item collaborative
filtering still has a major problem
sparsity the matrix of users versus
items has a ton of zeros
why is this though it's because users
watch a fraction of videos and videos
are only watched by a fraction of users
now let's take a look at this problem
more visually
our platform called youtube started with
five users a through e
and five videos one through five
in user user collaborative filtering
each user is represented by a five
dimensional vector
and each dimension of the vector is a
measure of how much they liked or
disliked each video
geometrically we can plot these users as
points
in this space 1. now with item item
collaborative filtering
each item or video in this case is
represented by a 5-dimensional vector
each dimension of this vector is a
measure of how much each user
either liked or disliked the particular
video
here each point is a video in this space
we'll call this space
two we can use either one of these
spaces to try
recommending videos to users using one
of the collaborative filtering
techniques that we discussed
the problem here is most of these points
have no information on most of the axes
so it should be possible to project them
onto a much smaller space
with not much loss of information right
in simpler terms we can reduce the five
dimensional user vectors in space one or
the five dimensional item vectors or
video vectors
in space two to say some two dimensional
vector
in another space like space three
by reducing dimensions we can increase
computation power
this is kind of like pca's
dimensionality reduction if you're
familiar with machine learning
you don't have to be but i'm just saying
this reduction in dimensions is done by
a technique called
matrix factorization i won't get into
the nitty gritties but i will explain at
a high level
so that you understand what it is and
why we use it
the user video matrix has tons of zeros
we established this this is true with
really high number of users or videos or
both by projecting it onto a smaller
space
we increase the computation efficiency
also
both users and videos are projected onto
the same space
so we can compare them directly the
result is that
videos closer to certain users are
likely to be recommended to them
and we no longer need to depend on
different videos themselves
to rate a video or depend on different
users themselves to
help rate a user and this technique
is the essence of matrix factorization
in matrix factorization it uses
something called svd which is singular
value decomposition
and we break down a matrix into a
product of three smaller matrices
without loss of information the first
matrix is a set of
user vectors in the new space the third
matrix is a set of video vectors in the
new space
but the second matrix represents the
strength of each dimension
in this new space it's a diagonal matrix
so only the diagonal elements are
non-zero
now some of you nerds out there just
might be curious how does it
find these three matrices it's by
optimizing
reconstruction loss between the original
user item matrix
and the product of these three matrices
so the matrix factorization technique
its major pro is that it overcomes the
scalability issue that collaborative
filtering has
we no longer care about the number of
users and items on the platform just to
rate a particular
user's interest in a particular item
so yeah it's much more computation
efficient
but now we have another problem human
interpretation
using this technique we will be able to
recommend videos to individuals
but unlike collaborative filtering
techniques the dimensions
we are projecting to aren't well defined
remember they are mathematically
determined while solving the
optimization problem
and they could be literally anything
from genre to video length to something
we may not even be able to comprehend as
humans
in other words magic factorization can
recommend videos
but it cannot tell us why it recommends
the video
this is vital information to drive new
business decisions
and without it we wouldn't know what
improvements can be made to increase
revenue for example
on our platform so yeah that's actually
a major con
okay until now we've developed some
recommender systems
so let's briefly recapitulate each
first off collaborative filtering in
user user collaborative filtering
the technique recommends videos to a
user based on similar
users whereas an item item collaborative
filtering
if we recommend videos based on similar
videos that a user liked
the advantages of collaborative
filtering are it's pretty simple to
implement
whereas the cons of this are well you
know youtube we have thousands of new
users and
videos too every day so neither user
based nor
item-based collaborative filtering scale
well
to address this enter a matrix
factorization
they transpose users and items to the
same space
and so they can be directly compared the
pros of this
are well predictions are independent of
the number of users
and videos on the platform so it scales
way better than collaborative filtering
the cons however are users and items are
transposed to a latent space
an unknown space so essentially users
are recommended videos but we have no
idea
why users are recommended these videos
on top of all this we made a major
assumption in the beginning
if user watches a video they have to
like or dislike it
but in the real world on youtube this is
not the case
users may comment rate subscribe or just
watch the video and do nothing in fact
most users do nothing so we need a
mechanism that
factors implicit feedback too
i'll talk more about implicit feedback
shortly
but let's get back to the main question
how does youtube recommend
videos what you're looking at right now
is the main architecture that google
published way back in 2017
about their model architecture for how
youtube actually recommends videos
and it's a two-stage process the first
is candidate generation
and the second is ranking candidate
generation takes
millions of videos on youtube and
filters out the potential videos that a
user may like
and the ranking part well takes these
videos these hundreds of videos that
were chosen from the first phase
and sorts them in the order of relevance
to the user
these videos are then shown to the user
let's now dive deeper into each of these
processes
until now we've only considered a
physical click
of the like or dislike button as a
factor to recommend videos to users
but like we mentioned before most users
don't provide
such explicit feedback so it makes sense
to collect information
about users ourselves based on this
paper that was released by google
here are some implicit features youtube
looks out for while
recommending videos one is watch history
which is the videos that you watched in
the recent past
the second is search history which is a
list of queries that you typed into
youtube's search bar to search for
certain results
then the third is user's geographic
location
and this makes sense because if you're
in mexico we get more spanish
creators or videos from more spanish
creators and if you're watching from say
india you're recommended more tech
videos
then next is device type so we have
mobiles tablets whether you're viewing
from a laptop or desktop
there's gender there's also age and
there's video freshness
and this is the age of the video i feel
like this is significant because
videos get the most views within the
first two days of their upload
moving forward i'll address these seven
features as
the user context because it's just a
shorter name
instead of saying the seven features
that we described before i'll just use
the phrase user context now we have this
information in hand but we need to
somehow
feed this into a neural network if you
don't know what a neural network is
don't worry about it no need to know the
details just know that is a magical
black box
that takes one type of variable as input
and converts it to another type of
variable at the output end
for the video recommender this input
will be the user features we just
described
the user context and the output would be
the set of
recommended videos but since a computer
needs to deal with these
we convert everything or re-encode
everything
into numbers and vectors let's consider
the encoding of input to a vector
for watch history we need to encode each
video into a fixed vector
and then we take an average of all of
these vectors to get a final vector for
watch history of all the videos next is
search history which
we do pretty much the same thing we
encode each query into a vector
and then take the average of these
queries to get the final query
history vector geographic location
embedding is just a vector representing
the country of the user
and all the other factors are just
encoded as scalars
we now take each of these vectors and
scalars and concatenate them into one
large vector and this final vector is
the input to our network
so the input to our network is sorted
out that's great
now for the output it's the set of
recommended videos
but how do we represent this in
traditional deep learning we model
each neuron as a probability the jth
neuron would be the probability of
watching
the video j completely it is well known
as the full softmax method
or better as just softmax but this would
mean that the number of videos
in the output layer be equal to the
number of videos on youtube
and well that number can be in the
millions it's way too large to compute
so the big question how do we feasibly
compute this and recommend videos the
most common solution
and the solution that youtube uses here
too is something called
candidate sampling instead of
considering
every single video on the platform for
recommendation
we only consider a subset of say 100 or
200 videos we select these 100 or 200
videos by
fancy term sampling videos from a
distribution
this concept gets very mathematical but
i'll explain it in a big picture way
enough to understand what's going on and
then i'll delve into specifics for the
nerds out there
first off where do we get our training
data from
we monitor every user's activity over
time
and every time a user clicks on a video
we have one
training sample and at this point we
would document the user context
so we have a number of pairs of user
contacts in the videos watched
for every user context we construct the
input vector x
i remember user context is a fancy word
that describes the seven features of the
user that we discussed before
and based on this user context we
determine a set of videos to recommend
to the person
which we call s here mathematically the
idea is to find the optimal set of
videos
that maximizes this equation
s here has a fixed size like 100 or 200
videos
and s is the set of candidate videos
that move on to the next stage
that is the 100 or 200 videos that the
algorithm thinks the user will
like the end result is
given a user's watch history search
history location and other information
and using that to maximize this equation
we get the appropriate set of videos to
recommend a user
now that is good enough to know what's
going on
but if you're a math nerd keep listening
q is a distribution where q of y given x
i
is the probability of watching a set of
videos
y given some user context x
i in our training data users either
watch a video
or they don't so q is a bernoulli
distribution that takes on two values
during training
one if the video was watched and zero if
it was not
watched it's customary machine learning
that while training we assume
a parametric distribution and we'll call
these parameters
theta using our training data with our
network we approximate this optimization
and during test time we use a sample
from p to give you a set of candidate
videos
when given context vector x
okay end of the math nerd sprint hope
this candidate sampling is clear to an
extent
i'll leave links in the description for
more details and also a link to the
paper too
now once we have candidate videos we now
need to go into the next step of
youtube's recommendation algorithm
the ranking phase the big picture is
that this involves sorting the candidate
videos in the order of relevance
each video is assigned a relevant score
higher the score
higher is the relevance for the user
context and the video is pushed up
higher onto the list
now to compute this score youtube uses
hundreds of features
some of these features are similar to
user context we discussed before
like watch history and search history
some of the video specific features
include how many videos has the user
watched from this channel
or when was the last time the user
watched a video on this topic
also the score of a video is upgraded
for every impression
so if a user doesn't click on the
recommended video
then the score of this video for the
user context is decreased
and it drops down the list with such
frequent updates to the score
and hundreds of features to consider i
think you can see why we need
candidate sampling to weed out the less
relevant videos
before we rank videos it would be insane
to just rank 100
000 or millions of videos every single
time user clicked
on a video
now another big question how exactly are
these scores computed
you may have guessed this but the scores
are directly proportional to
watch time in fact in youtube's ranking
neural network
these values are equal so higher the
expected watch time of the video for a
given user
higher is its score off the bat i find
this weird because it's obvious that
longer videos have
high raw expected watch time and so the
ranking algorithm will likely recommend
longer videos which is in alignment with
what a number of creators are
complaining about these days
if you want more technical details on
how the ranking algorithm predicts
expected watch time
put your nerd house on for a bit okay
just put them on
youtube uses a technique called weighted
logistic
regression to come up with these scores
it takes hundreds of features of the
video and user is input
and it spits out the relevant score
which is also the expected watch time of
the video
now why does this work let's build some
intuition
we want to assign a high score to a
video if we believe the user
will view it for a long time in other
words if the
odds of them watching a video for a long
time are high
we want to assign it a higher score the
odds is proportional to the probability
of watching a video
it's actually the ratio of probability
of watching a video to the probability
of
not watching it but here we are
weighting each of the videos differently
based on watch time so
let's say that n is the number of
candidate videos from candidate sampling
which is like i don't know 100 or 200 or
some large number
then k is the number of videos which are
actually watched by the user
so n minus k will be the number of
videos that were considered as
candidates
but not watched by the user
now videos that are not watched don't
have watch time
so it is assigned a watch time of one
second
so the denominator just becomes the
number of videos the user didn't click
on
but was recommended to them weighted
logistic regression
maximizes the odds of seeing a video
that is watched
and minimizes the odds of seeing a video
that is not watched
this is similar to the philosophy of
normal logistic regression
but the difference here is well waits we
wait the videos watched
much more heavily than the weights of
videos not watched
simplifying this mathematically we can
assume the number of videos watched is
actually really less compared to the
number of candidate videos
and in the end we get the odds nearly
equal to the expected watch time
of a video for a given user
now that's the basic math now put on
your technical hats
we're going to construct a neural
network in a similar way as the
candidate sampling network
during training the last fully connected
layer is able to learn the
logarithm of the odds or the log odds
the logit so while testing we take the
exponent of this value
to get the odds just the raw odds of the
user watching the video
and this odds is the relevant score of
the video
for the given user and just as we proved
it is also the expected watch time
and that's the gist of youtube's
algorithm and the deep learning approach
for building a recommender system
so cool let's summarize everything that
i just mentioned in this video
we started out with the definition of a
recommender system just using youtube as
a context
we went into details about the types of
recommender systems
one is collaborative filtering where we
use ratings of different users to
predict if
a particular user will like video but
the disadvantage of this in a general
store or general situation is
new users tend to join the platform at a
very high rate
so that doesn't scale well with users a
solution
is to use videos instead of users to
determine or to make predictions
about whether a user will like a
particular item
however here in youtube users are
continuously signing into the platform
and videos are also continuously updated
to the platform
so collaborative filtering in general
doesn't scale well regardless of whether
it's with respect to users or
items videos another problem is sparsity
too much storage space too much
computation complexity
for the user video matrix a solution to
this is to use
the second major technique that we
described matrix factorization
this technique decomposes the user video
matrix into three matrices
geometrically it projects the user
vector and a video vector into the same
space so they can be directly compared
we would recommend items whose video
vectors are closer to the user's vector
the problem here is the users and the
items are
transposed to an unknown space we know
the video to recommend to the user but
we don't know why we are recommending
this video to the user
and then finally we introduce a deep
learning technique to construct a
recommendation system
and explain youtube's algorithm using
this approach
the recommendation system is actually
split into two parts the first is
candidate sampling
where we select hundreds of potentials
of videos from the millions of videos on
the platform based on user interest
and we also took a look at a list of
features that the algorithm considers
the second is the ranking algorithm
where we assign a relevant score to each
video and sort videos accordingly this
is done using
weighted logistic regression which is
the weighted version of logistic
regression
where the weights of training videos are
assigned based on
watch time there are hundreds of
features that the algorithm uses
but youtube has not made most of them
public
so are recommendations on youtube solely
based on watch time
well that's actually not quite the case
because in the two
processes that we discussed the first is
candidate sampling
we actually get these candidate samples
based on
other factors such as what the user
previously saw before
or what queries the user may have typed
into the search bar
but it's in the second phase of ranking
that we do predominantly use
watch time in order to generate the
rankings of
our videos and this is probably why you
see longer content
being recommended more than shorter
content even though both of them are
actually still
based on watch history and search
history and that's it
hope you guys liked the video hope you
learned about recommender systems in
general and also how
youtube recommends videos using their
deep learning techniques
if you like the video give it a like
subscribe for more awesome content
it took a long time to make so a
subscribe would really be well
appreciated
keep up to date with my content and i
will see you guys in the next one bye
bye